до війни
віктору був менеджером з продажу
промислового плавно не в першотравневому
луганщині і то первин проти волонтерів
українському центрі допомога біженцям з
донбасу
знає і оплачую роботу за рік жити
українській столиці та
віктор так in з них за оренду шатла його
пологи на відео близько 130 євро
державної компенсації вік
що влада знайди варіанти тем вартових
вже скарби проц intel
наприклад завершили і треба буду в
скільки таких недобудов скільки таких
недуг стояти не введені в експлуатацію
ніхто на кожен рахунок і вид так тоу тревал
і оповіді владу не хочу об'єктом
годин і зло
олексієм ніхто не займає ніхто не
займати на міжнародні конференції у
до верби вмовляти і околиця допомогти ти
виїхавши з донбасу
граматики організації України вимагаєте
виду ряду створи ти україни міністерство
для допомоги вигаданим прояснений team
to вріжте
розрубає і дорожню карту хіба за неї
з них проблем національну стратегію
безпосередньо прописався хто вид по
мигдальної за такі plan de ye ye ye
ye ye столітті терміну типу набату реалізовано
який фінансово не потрібно для течуть не
спільного натиснувши на знак дає винних
ресурсі ви фінансово не цього чиниш його
заходу печінка череди
то мети ідеальний писарем для топ ще по
результату серед міжнародних донорів
Самого такого документа джекають витка і
його та між народом організації за крима
він а джеклін вигаданих надсилаєте
яким потрібно робота-то житло є
шалю даяки завершилася біля районів
підконтрольних сепаратистам і потрібно
muy tard адагум вона
is an important важливі його
щоб українське уряд то донори обігнало
і свою сус чи щуп за б скаче і людей
але й пхи ну а ж потреба розумних різанини то
закласти кручений дивани перебуває і
families
а корінь тощо. Левін
україна сама стіна не зможемо ви вирішите
проблему біженців поважаючи інший експерт
це кликай окраїною євросоюзу
треба так і його суть його фінансову
допомогу бензин тек ніж міжнародної
skillet вона готова тут в Україні
допомогти всім людям тем годин
переміщеним особливом тільки луїсі у нас
намагається покинутий україну діаграмі
цифра нас будди на клік ти зруйнованого
ний алорен ходж і повернуто сеулі для
місця winxp одягається луганська штока
область пдд під контроль україни
держава знайди ресурси для того, щоб
треба додати качка століття раді ти на
винні жнива